bonsoir des voix l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs de retour
pour cette année 2011 ce nouveau
millénaire et loi la pêche parce que
beaucoup beaucoup d'événements se
termine et démarre beaucoup d'événements
se termine bon tout d'abord bonne année
à tous effectivement puisque c'est la
grande rentrée celle en 2001 qui
commence et échiquéenne mans c'est tout
à fait au point puisque donc il ya déjà
la fin de ce championnat du monde dont
on avait fait nombreuses spéciales est
également plein d'événements qui
commence stéphane plein et lundi
commence alors on va tout de suite
championnat du monde en avait dit que
effectivement à priori ça devrait être
ça devait être jouée après trois parties
parce que là on avait déjà gagné 2-0 et
ça s'est pas démenti puisque sur ans a
pris une troisième but d'affiner oui
directement dans la continuité il s'est
fait proprement massacre à mi-chemin à
thann un an d'après le centre dans une
française il a tenu comme un fou ne
laissant aucune chance à shirov qui est
sacrifié une pièce puis une deuxième
bref rien est arrivé à nantes a gagné
trois et demi 1/2 shirov n'a tiré qu'une
seule nul dans ce match c'est une
véritable explosion
ouais c'est une explosion mort il faut
signaler que kramnik a commenté
d'ailleurs ce championnat du monde
estime que la demande est le vainqueur
normal de ceux de ce championnat et que
chez rough était probablement un peu en
dessous de son niveau habituel sur ce
tournoi mais il arrive quand même un
final c'est pas mal c'est pas mal à
noter quand même au passage que shirov a
perdu des points d'eau on se tourne donc
on peut être vice-champion du monde et
perdre des points l'oph c'est c'est une
remarque un petit peu surprenante
en tout cas bravo hollande et est-ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que là ça devient
très compliqué puisqu'on a donc à nantes
sur le tour du monde
a priori quand même assez légitime on ne
pourra pas dire comme on disait avec
kalichman que c'est un coup de bol c'est
difficile parce que c'était le favori
l'a gagné le tournant fièrement
sont pas laissés surprendre oui et de
l'autre côté dans notre ami qui a battu
kasparov bon mais qui bon il ya un
problème
alors c'est plus compliqué que ça
stéphane puisqu'il faut faire également
intervenir kasparov et shirov là dedans
alors donc nous avons kasparov qui bat à
nantes mais qui perd contre kramnik
chronique qui bat kasparov
mais qui perd contre shirov et shirov
qui bat krainik mais qui perd contre
allende voilà bref lequel des quatre et
champion en tout cas ils ont tous perdu
au moins un match dans leur vie donc
pour l'instant c'est le flou le plus
total
alors voilà ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
l'idéal c'est qu'il ya un match organisé
entre kramnik et un arbre pour mettre
les choses au point
bon le problème c'est aussi le
changement de formule qu'il ya un match
organisé entre chronique et annonce ça
serait idéal ce serait idéal mais c'est
dans les reins il s'entraîne d'envisager
un message il ya un match de prestige
est dir est mais bon tout le monde sait
que ça ce que ça voudrait dire mais par
contre bon effectivement après laquelle
la vraie question en fait ce que la
vraie question que pose expérience c'est
pas tellement de savoir qui est le plus
fort c'est de savoir comment on définit
le championnat du monde
est ce que si c'est le système fi des
cas au bout d'un mois où est-ce qu'on
revient un système avec un match à la
fin qui est quand même a priori plus les
plus médiatiques en tout cas l'un des
miens enfin bon même sens en parler au
niveau médias je ne sais pas quelle est
la forme la plus juste on pourrait
peut-être organiser un tournoi cadre que
le ronde avec ces quatre joueurs n'ont
même tendance à vassan d'autres
problèmes mais c'était évidemment est-ce
que c'est pas le même style de jeu aussi
quelqu'un balle l'autre 4 0 tout de
suite ça fausse le tournoi je pense
qu'il ya pas de solution de toute façon
ces quatre très bons joueurs qui sont en
tête mais même en boxe stéphane on sait
qui est championne du monde dont on sait
pas qui est le meilleur boxeur c'est
toujours pareil
oui voilà bon alors donc bref un an le
champion du monde fis des cramique
champion du monde
kasparov au moins dire brain games et
puis donc début 2001 alors le match
actuelle qui nous intéresse dont on va
parler aujourd'hui c'est un match entre
kramnik et l'écossé la première sortie
de chronique en tant que champion du
monde
on va y revenir tout de suite et ensuite
en janvier on ya le super tournoi qui va
peut-être mettre les choses au point
le tournoi des 15 et où les dix
meilleurs joueurs mondiaux sont là donc
kasparov kramnik canarder shirov donc ça
va ça va sûrement chauffer et on va
aller là bas fait un reportage spécial
oui tout à fait on vous ramènera des
images donc fin janvier puisque le
tournoi commence de 12 janvier pour être
précis et finit le 28
donc on ira en cours de tournoi 1000 de
tournois ce qui fait que fin janvier
vous aurez un reportage en images alors
ça va être extrêmement chaud puisque il
y en a qu'on a tendance à oublier dans
cette période c'est quand même kasparov
kasparov qui n'a pas joué depuis sa
défaite contre cramique qui doit se
préparer se prépare et se préparer et
qui va arriver vraisemblablement en
super forme et en tout cas prêt à en
découdre
et puis bon il faut pas oublier les
outsideurs parce qu'on sait pas ce qu'il
peut sortir de là ils vont a priori ça
devrait pas échapper la victoire et
devrait pas échapper à ces quatre là oui
oui tout ça serait difficile alors par
contre à leur première sortie de crâne
icom tant que champion du monde ça c'est
intéressant alors c'est un match
de prestige c'est pas un match officiel
dans ces des parties rapides mais bon
kramnik joue contre eux peter l'écho
dans son match annuel je dirais presque
standard quoi oui c'est à dire qu'on
peut pas vraiment dire stéphane que
c'est un match de prestige appartient
moment où il ya le champion du monde
quand il est là il remet d'une certaine
manière son titre en jeu
psychologiquement en tout cas aux yeux
du monde et j'y tiens donc la cram ni
contre peter les cours ce n'est pas un
adversaire facile plus tard l'écho le
jeune hongrois puisqu'on sait qu'il est
systématiquement dans les cinq six
meilleurs joueurs du monde
il vient juste après ce bloc de 4 way
donc il est extrêmement fort en semi
rapide il joue pas mal non plus c'est un
des joueurs les plus solides qui
existent donc ça donne il amène à
climbach chalenge kasparov il avait
battu l'instant sur une partie semi
rapides à francfort à francfort
exactement avant d'être enfin après
avoir été gagnant dans la première
partie
donc il a battu qu'à sports forme et
rapide c'est pas mal alors il avait
battu l'année dernière dans ce même
match qui sait il ya une société
allemande qui sponsorise les causes pour
ça qu'ils amassent chaque année il avait
battu l'année dernière le champion du
monde fis des qualifs man
mais cette fois il s'attaque aux
championnes human being games à noter
qui s'est fait éliminer au cham pirate
du nom de fille départ kalichman en
décembre mais bon il est tombé malade un
fait un oui alors ça c'est ce qu'on a
dit après le tournoi bon c'était prendre
un vrai pendant mais l'écho avait vrai
simplement pas envie d'en parler pendant
le tournoi ça se comprend
effectivement c'était quand même un
match marathon qui a duré très longtemps
puisque à une longue série de départage
- tu dois congo 2 nuls et c'était en
mort subite khalifa n'a fini par
remporter une partie
l'écho a été éliminée de ce champion du
monde mais maintenant contre krainik
nouveau challenge parties rapides
c'est intéressant et d'ailleurs le match
tient ses promesses
mais ma chienne ses promesses alors on a
cru que ça allait finalement se pas se
faire que d'un côté puisque au bout de
quatre parties crown est mené 2 0 2
victoires et 2 nuls 2-0 et
arrive la cinquième partie et les corps
viennent on va revenir dans le match
oui alors peut-être qu'on va détailler
un peu plus ses quatre premières parties
première partie kravica les blancs les
coaches london fields et se fait tout un
tout simplement pulvérisé
donc ça rappelle un peu kasparov quand
une grünfeld le championnat du monde qui
se fait massacrer qu'il large au plus
après effectivement les cons de la
partie ça c'est une première remarque
donc ravis qu'une fois de plus la bonne
file dans des salles une fois on se fait
massacrer on arrête ensuite les qu avec
les blancs n'obtient rien contre
stéphane la berlinoise
quand même des cas les a pas oubliés du
haut la berlinoise allied donc qui
rejoue la l'ouverture en ti caspar ans
donc ça veut dire que il va sûrement
l'utiliser de cette année et peut-être
encore temps de kasparov à bala et
apparemment il a trouvé une formule qui
lui plaît puisqu'il fait nul facilement
dans la première et il remporte la 2ème
berlinoise donc gagné une partie avec
les noirs les co ayant été un petit peu
dans le doute un petit peu dans le flou
ne sachant pas trop quoi faire d'une
ouverture hésitant la douleur chronique
lui n'a pas eu de problème
il a son plan il a exécuté donc bref
après quatre parties d'aucuns pour
krainik deux nuls
ça semblait vraiment facile pour la
ligne 1 qui allait enchaîner une fois de
plus avec les blancs dans la cinquième
oui hélas c'est là que se réveillent
dans ce match ô combien de partis à 8 c
8 ou 6 non c'est en 12 parties s'est
tous dit pardon 12 parties semi-rapides
merci jour 6 jours aux deux parties par
aujourd'hui étant le jour de repos
voilà donc on va voir cette cinquième
partie dans ce qui prouve que finalement
il va sympathie facile que ça pour
kramnik on a eu peur quand même que ce
match soit une démonstration
donc on va passer à cette cinquième
partie entre cramique donc champion du
monde
ban games et
peter l'écho voilà tout de suite ça va
arriver
alors voilà donc cavalier f3 le coup
préféré de bladinières krainik oui alors
nous allons donc passer en incrustation
à droite de l'échiquier
ces cinq c4 donc là ça rappelle un peu
la dernière partie kasparov chronique
alors que stéphane est arrivé voilà il
déclaré en petit à droite up qu'elle est
une anglaise symétrique stéphane est
lapidaire des couches le coup hausse est
aussi à noter que normalement eh bien on
joue plutôt le coup qu'elle ait des huit
ans et six monarques également g3 ça
c'est un fou en fouillant piétons on est
déjà vu ça des six réaction contre ce
fou voilà cercle fous ces huit l'avenir
sur la case bessette et s'opposer sur
cette diagonale blanche à la sortie du
four blanc sur le kg 2 bon si j'ai deux
options possibles fou 17 petit rock
maintenant les noirs que font-ils et
bien elle continue à sortir leurs pièces
et c'est important dans l'ouverture il
vous faut 7 avec l'idée de faire le
petit rock tout simplement
maintenant il ya plusieurs plans pour
les blancs dans cette pétition stéphane
qui sont tous très intéressants par
exemple on peut jouer une véritable
anglaise entre le coût des deux des
trois cantines véritable anglaise ça
veut dire qu'on aura cette structure la
fameuse structure du dragon oui qui est
celle là qui fait un peu son vote il
pensait à un dragon
ça veut dire qu'on laissera le pion des
sur la case d3 incitatives et ensuite on
va jouer tour b 1 à 3 et b4 on va
commencer notre contre jeu sur enfin
notre jeu plutôt sur le carreau chez les
dames
ça ça serait normal maintenant cram nick
a une autre idée
il prend le centre quand même et ça a
priori on peut pas dire que ce soit une
mauvaise conception puis ce conseil dans
les ouvertures il faut en au centre anti
femmes tout à fait donc là l'écho
ça crée une menace directe au passage la
menace est évidemment de jouer des
quatre des cinq qui boucherait le fourbe
et c'est thibaut cheval fou 17 qui
prendrait de l'espace et ce serait
terrible les noirs sont donc normalement
objet de prendre au centre là on peut
reprendre du cavalier
mais ça les changera et les fous noufou
17 contre le projet de ramener cas pas
envie de simplifier la position pour
l'instant est tout d'abord en décalage
c'est affaiblir un peu le roi blanc oui
mais qui sait ça donne blessés légers
mais j'ai le principal étant surtout la
simplification d'un point d'écart par
contre c'est donc ça ça évite des
changes des fous on a aimé c'est un
énorme retour sains et non un énorme
bassin des avantages s'est fait exploser
en cinq ans dit il faut jamais sortir la
dame trop tôt puisque j'ai tout de suite
les coûts en profite
il sort son cavalier sur la casse et six
attaquants l'armée dont il gagne en
quittant gagne un temps puisque la dame
et objets de reboucher et en plus on
voit pas de la bonne case pour cette
dame donc rien bien sûr la case f4f 4une
t as pas très joli on va me rappelle une
perte de chronique en place par ansa
oui tout à fait dans cette partie là si
la 10e ares c'est la partie dinars est
énorme près du monde auprès du monde
c'est déjà de là je crois la 12e partie
où la 14e c'était une des dernières
parties entre amis qui avaient des
blancs et ils avaient souffert dans
cette partie ici il avait aussi mais
tellement acheter parce que qu'est-ce
qu'on fait avec pas encore fait mais
c'est un peu différent ou petit rock
tour d un don qu'est ce qui se passe
dans cette position si les noirs
arrivent à jouer 17 des 5
il y aura des échanges au centre et la
position sera égale way une chronique ne
veut pas permettre ça bien entendu les
blancs doivent essayer de garder au
maximum le plus longtemps possible à
leur avantage de développement et
surtout il faut étouffer des noirs il
faut faire ce qu'on appelle un étau de
ma roxy ces termes être influencés
cartes et éventuellement un autre angle
4 tenir le centre et essayé de presser
les noirs finir de les cantonner sur une
deux ou trois rangées voilà et ne pas
les laisser sortir de leur bois gardés
quatre ans j'ai pour soi et quand on est
une war 3 oui d'amd vite donc la propre
aux échanges des dames est tout à fait
mais en fait chronique ce qu'indique
s'en fout il faut un temps fou c'est à
dire que ils n'échangent pas les dames
il n'évite pas les changes les dames il
joue simplement un bon coup ils jouent
le coup à eux deux quatre coups qui donc
on voit blindes complètement la casse
des cinq puisque donc dire que les noirs
ne pourront pas vraiment
je vais d7 d5 le coup qui les auraient
libéré mais en même temps il permet
d'échanger les dames que les comptes ne
fait pas alors les qu'on ne fait pas ce
qu'on dit souvent c'est que c'est bien
de ramener un pion vers le centre sert
si la leko échange les dames
oui évidemment on prend des tokio
probablement non alors c'est pas évident
stefan sip évident du tout d'un point
j'aurais appris avec le pion noyer c'est
intéressant on prendrait corruption ça
c'est à cause des conséquences c'est que
ça fait lui la structure depuis ouais
mais à plus de pions vers le centre fait
autrement je sais pas peut-être il faut
prendre un peu fou avec le foot ça a
l'air assez logique quand même dans la
mesure où on va peut-être pouvoir le
mettre sur la caisse des 6 m le kenyan
b5 profité de l'affaiblissement des
cases noires ça m'a l'air d'être plus
que dans l'esprit plus dans l'esprit
tout à fait donc 4 les connais charge
pas les dames probablement à cause de
foudre en écaille les cinq îles jour le
conte 17 et 6 et maintenant on est
complètement dans ce qu'on appelle le
hérisson stéphane alors pourquoi le
vérisme alors qu'est-ce que ça brison ce
génie pic hippiques
et puis donc alors c'est soit une pique
c'est cette formation on va la voir dans
un instant ça va devenir chroniqueuse au
b2 b3 pourquoi pas et la déco joue à 6
cl à c'est un hérisson c'est un hérisson
voilà elle enlevait son c'est ça donc
après le dragon vous avez levé irisson
voilà c'est normal donc structure
hérisson c'est à dire qu'à tout moment
les noirs peuvent jouer soit b5
déjà on va montrer ce qu'ils contrôlent
des 5 et contrôlera tous à ces contrôles
c'est comme des pics en fait mal en fait
c'est ça donc ça défigure ils sont le
hérisson empêche les blancs complètement
d'aller sur cette quatrième rangée
l'objectif des noirs dans cette position
ça va être de préparer
donc là on va enlever on va enlever tout
ça c'est de préparer la vence c'est
compliqué rires de beaucoup et hop vous
voyez le hérisson c'est ça ça pique
c'est de préparer l'avant soit duction b
en b 5 soit du pion des en d5
alors ça paraît curieux parce que ils
vont pas le jouer tout de suite
ils vont attendre longtemps et pourtant
il semblerait que les blancs malgré le
fait qu'ils aient plus d espace n'est
pas de plan n'est pas d'emplacement pour
leur pièce pour empêcher la poussée
efficace du plan b ou du chant des donc
c'est très très curieux comme formation
ouais mais on dit souvent aussi quand
même avec le
les taux de maroci que c'est bien ça
mais ça le problème c'est que les blancs
peuvent pas trop bouger aussi wii voit
les noirs ne peuvent pas bouger mais les
blancs non plus puisque la structure
locale si elle bouge ça affaiblit de
tout de suite tout à fait alors les
blancs tous les coups de pions des
blancs sont très responsables dans cette
position il faut il faire très attention
alors en voyant cette partie pendant le
direct j'étais très très curieux de
savoir comment kramnik allait jouer
effectivement il n'a pas été convaincant
mais c'est très délicat à jouer pour les
blancs alors il commence par je fous b2
bon pourquoi pas on marie logis oui
normalement on n'aime pas de mettre trop
le fou sur cette grande diagonale
parce que les noirs très souvent joué le
coup au 6 e 5 donc ils bouchent le fou
et avec la structure des six au simple
four b2 se retrouvent momentanément hors
course
ouais donc bon cb2 on peut pas encore
reproché ce coup mais c'est pas
forcément le meilleur emplacement
peter les cobras place ces pièces d'être
c'est cette dame c'est cette donc
probablement là il va placer pièces dont
seul a commencé puisque les semi ouverte
pour lui avec le plein peut-être à terme
donc toujours pareil de joris au death
is death and sarah bessie smith and will
be dead dams et 7 pour l'instant c'est
de n'être une tour sur la colonne c'est
stéphane latour à 8 ans évite de mettre
de la puissance là sur cette colonne
ensuite on va mettre la tour f 800 la
case peu vite et ensuite on va rapatrier
nos pièces sur des bonnes cases mais on
va voir parce que la façon dont l'écho a
joué très très classique très
conventionnel et c'est apparemment très
fort de ses 7 h trois grammy qui sait
pas trop où aller puisqu'il a pas de
levier pion à proprement parler à il
peut pas percer l'un pour l'instant taux
avancé vite
voilà donc pour l'instant et quoi encore
des coups bon allez blanc aussi variés
mais pour y jouer tu auras c'est un fil
blanc oui mais tout ça c'est bien
qu'est-ce que ça préfère c'était ça ne
prépare rien ça développe la pièce
ouais c'est un joli coup mais on va là
quel est le il faut voir il faut faire
un plan un hacker alors voilà c'est ça
c'est que même si on peut pas se penser
ne peut pas avancer
il est contrôlé et la case c'est simple
on peut le montrer oui donc même s'ils
ont une tour derrière ça sert à rien
derrière ce pion puisque la casse est
celle qui est contrôlé par deux pions
noirs donc moins d'options noir est
quand même pas mal de pièces aussi mal
avait pas mal d'atouts donc on va pas
trop c'est une case et on peut pas on ne
peut rien faire donc le pion doit rester
un c4 donc du coup effectivement met
rupteur derrière même si ça semble
naturel c'est pas efficace ça serait une
mesure défensive tout simplement
roenick a paru durer comme ça il joue
des mots cette dame 3,23 bon mais un
oeil sur l'option b 6 on ne sait jamais
oui à noter que ça peut être une
faiblesse
oui mais c'est toujours très simple pour
les noirs de défendre en qualifs 617
c'était pas bon a priori pour l'instant
pas vraiment d'idée la dame était mal
classés entre 4 c'est tout ce qu'on peut
dire il la replace en de trois cavaliers
aux cinq donc la responsable ouais les
colas propos effectivement puisque les
blues pourraient échanger avec les noirs
qui reprendrait du pion alors on va on
va envisager puisque c'est c'est un coup
critique c'est très important de
comprendre ce qui se passe après cavale
et franck est rayé pourquoi on dit que
ces critiques tout simplement parce que
ça change la structure de pions ouais
c'est écrasant voilà il faut reprendre
du pian ça fait moins doués en plus sa
ceinture doublé pour les noirs mais
alors qu'est ce qu'on voit maintenant si
on regarde d'un peu plus près on voit
que le fossé de va revenir en c5 avec
ton très belle diagonale l'a peut-être
même en d4
ouais parce que nos soeurs à la casse
des quatre qui est forte mais il ya le
pion f2 aussi que foot ap ce pion et
mine de rien je ne sais pas forcément le
plus important mais il y avait quatre
aussi qu'ils en pensent c'est vrai mais
ça empêchera les pions de se protéger et
enfin c'est embêtant quand c'est
embêtant et les noirs obtiendrez un jeu
très dynamique
on peut même envisager par exemple la
manoeuvre la manoeuvre touré fuite suivi
de tour des quatre ça c'est possible
c'est un plan également d'en faire un
seul 45 et par al même si les deux
labels et il contrôle bien la casse des
quatre et c'est bon pour les noirs
surtout on voit ici que les pièces des
noirs sont plus actifs ils sont plus
actifs dans la mesure où blanc par
exemple est hors jeu
bloqué par son propre piège 4 donc quand
vous voyez cabello 5 si vous avez et non
dans cette position est bien
ne le prenez pas ce serait une faute
positionnelle krainik joue cavalier des
quatre banques et à et par contre ils
menacent peut-être de jouer f2f 4
peut-être oui alors évidemment la relève
de f4 à chasseral qui medios en voilà
mais ça affaiblit les blancs en veut un
insert que le roi blanc va se retrouver
un peu à l'air le feu qui ont f qui
avance toujours trop tôt un phare howrse
jamais assez quelle est l'idée du
dernier coup de crâne qui vient de jouer
cavalier en d4
pourquoi est-ce qu'ils de mélasse les
femmes c'est pour contrôler la case des
ils empêchent les nordistes bessalah il
que ce coup puisse être ne serait ce
qu'envisager par peter est donc pour
l'instant chronique joue un peu en ils
empêchent les noirs d'exécuter leur plan
à défaut d'avoir lui-même un plan alors
là au 16e cool et qu'on joue h6 en corse
à son cou quad attentes
c'est un coup d'attentes oui c'est un
coup typique du hérisson bon de faire un
coup tranquille quoi tient le coup et il
de toute façon puisque ça a fait la
petite saynète pour le roi c'est
toujours le cas là effectivement a
priori rien ne presse puisque les noirs
sont bien quand on est dans leur camp
bien c'est bien solide et c'est un coup
préventif aussi parce qu'on peut dire
qu'un des plans des blancs c'est pousser
le plonger nager 3,4 et social pour
chasser ce cavalier si c'est le cas il
ya six museler un peu le fouet cette
ensuite joué h4 donc ce couac si c'est
pas mal parce que ils contrôlent
laquelle j'ai cinq en avance encore
intéressant tour des deux bonbons pour
quoi pourrir là de répliquer ce genre
nos goûts un nom alors on peut
l'expliquer facilement chronique est
prévu de mettre ses tours sur les
colonnes d et f
voici son plan il veut mettre des tours
sur ses 2 colonnes là alors qu'est ce
qui est idéal dans cette position si on
la regarde bien il peut jouer tour f1
suite tant d un ce qui prend de temps et
qui mettra les tours sur ces deux cas
cela va maintenant avec son coup tours
d2 au coup d'après s'il joue tour f1 on
verra que ça aura pris de temps
également les tours sont sur ces deux
cases là on est plus souple on pourquoi
parce que on peut facilement doubler les
tours ensuite voilà une semaine dans une
arrière lot pour bien contrôler une
colonie voilà exactement qui souvent on
sera prêts à doubler les toits donc ça
gagne entre guillemets un temps on a
gagné montant potentiellement même si
c'est pas forcément important touré fut
vite ça c'est bien joué aux rayons x les
femmes voilà sept tours peu voilà cirque
ont l'oeil noir pourrait avoir des idées
de jeu des cinq par exemple maintenant
oui des 5 tout à fait là c'est vraiment
à l'ordre du jour dont 100 parce que là
il ya beaucoup de choses qui s'ouvre la
dame serait attaquée par la tour 8
on pourrait sacrifier des choses et ça
pourrait marcher alors pour l'instant ce
n'est pas encore d'actualité dans la
mesure où il ya trop de pièces qu'il ya
eu la colonne ou encore des pieds mais
attention messieurs pour tous un
potentiel se dégage plus vite mieux
qu'on ne le pense
vladimir kramnik du roi charaf s'est pas
trop quoi faire ça c'est vraiment le
coup
alors ce qu'on disait il a peut-être pas
envie du f4 parce que ça affaiblit la
diagonale vers le roy we will not
j'observais les pièces bleus voilà qui
sont donc redevenu noir ces lieux ouache
un cavalier e en dès cette date encore
non alors ça ne va pas du tout alors
justement attention on dirait un coup
date c'est un coup très important
stéphane pourquoi et bien on replace ce
cavalier alors rappelons que ce cavalier
vient de la case c6 pas fasciné à quoi
docteur en échange il est venu à eux
cinq ans maintenant il revient aux 17es
ou va-t-il est bien de va vers cette
garde ses 5 ha voilà le plan voilà et
donc à partir de ces cinq on aura trois
pièces qui attaquent le pian pilonnent
le pion au carvi turin 4-1 on le voit
donc ça c'est encore désagréable et en
plus après ça soutient la percée des six
des 5 de façon très efficace
vladimir kramnik ps4 il faut quand même
qu'ils fassent découvrir voilà et jfk
donc ça explique un peu le cours a h1n1
qu'il n'y a pas de l'eau il n'y a pas de
possibilité pour les noirs de faire un
clouage d'un miroir
oui et tout à fait être quatre ici donc
c'est difficile
suite alors faut ensuite de l'écho alors
un coup tranquille mais ça libère la
tour voilà vous voyez là on voit que
c'est un langage c'est là que la lave
les normes on as probablement de jouer
deux des cinq dessins qui à leur
retraite ce patient et non en fait ils
menacent même on va expliquer pourquoi
kramix autour f1 tout répond alors là
depuis le temps qu'on le dit il
semblerait que toutes les conditions
soient réunies pour un t5 réussissent à
pas l'air bon ben si orelsan tout
simplement alors pas tout de suite
stéphane peut-être à la transition prend
d'abord peut-être en dessin qui ont su
pas sûr non le 5
nous sommes tout de suite à leur banc le
5 ça fait très bon puisque la le khalife
si cette attaque et là pas de case oui
oui ok elle avait peu pâle 1,17 tout de
suite donc certes il y en a sept ou 1,5
et bien tout simplement ça à perdre le
tournant plus sa paire le plan des
scènes filmées en plus comme à le placer
en plus il serait mal classé 20e place
donc ici après tout la fin il n'y a pas
de
il n'y a pas de menace les noirs peuvent
pas jouer des 5 il joue donc peter
l'écho d'un bien vite
encore un coup qui n'a l'air de rien
alors d'amener vite alors ça c'est un
coup c'est le coup malin ce genre
d'opposition parce que dame est une
banque ça libère la tour c 8
ça libère l'action à tour ses huit ça
peut être utile mais surtout ses potes
ça peut aider pour pousser le betis b5
oui tout à fait alors on voit beaucoup
de rayons x voilà sept tours en 1 8
il va peut-être mettre le soudan à 8
l'écho on est peut-être plus tard le
foot des 7 vallées à 8 et la dame pourra
soutenir l'avancée du pinot noir voilà
ce qui va pouvoir attaquer la chaîne des
puys ans et tout le respect c'est
d'autant plus que la dame on sait cette
était pas spécialement bien placé
puisque il vaut mieux avoir une tour sur
une colonne ouverte une dame ça c'est un
petit coup mal en fait c'est une toutes
ces techniques de placement sont très
sont retrouvés sont faciles à sohar se
rappeler et sont en général bonnes dans
ce type de position oui c'est
extrêmement connue c'est extrêmement
connu un des premiers à mettre ce
système à la mode c'était bobby fischer
stéphane voilà qui a gagné beaucoup
beaucoup de parties entendent hérisson
et donc savait à l'époque un peu choqué
il a joué comme ça sur trois rangées de
loin ça marche un peu alanine au beach
toile hypermoderne l hyper moderne g4g 4
alors ça c'est un coup aux responsables
mais ils voient que signifie rien grammy
qui voit qu'il va se prendre des sites
bilingues ou des six des symptômes ou
tard oui les noirs vont avoir un voleur
potentiel de pièces qui va se libérer
donc il se dit bon faut essayer de faire
quelque chose pour avoir du con tre jeu
a noté stéphane dans cette question le
gros problème des blancs c'est qu'ils
ont beaucoup plus de territoire à tenir
et que donc effectivement dès que le jeu
s'ouvre et bien les pièces noires
doivent aller de tous les copies des
deux côtés les noirs ont peu de place
pour vous pour nous sauver alors
évidemment très chez les uns comme le
revers de la médaille c'est que si les
noirs n'arrive pas à ouvrir le jeu et
bien tout simplement ils vont se faire
étouffer comme dans un sac plastique là
j'ai quatre noms pourquoi pas peter des
coups alors oui dans la salle ça
commence à être chaud pour la menace
peut-être g5 avec l'option eps vii de
peter l'écho est plus protégé du tout
ouais donc ce bar le roi par le roi que
par le roi oui mais s'il ya une tour qui
commence à aller dessus c'est
désagréable
peter les couches au km 10 h 7/4 et h7
ben ça alors ça dure expliquer ça alors
ça prévient gsm cents cavaliers pas
attaqué oui mais faut à ce que les
banques ne pourraient pas quand même
joué gsm ou alors je sens que ça a pas
l'air extraordinaires dans la mesure où
après chez cinq pions proches et ça les
rendrait probablement il faudrait
reprendre du poids ce qui est loin des
meneurs du centre et ça permettrait
peut-être de revenir en 5
tout à fait voilà ma pièce de cinq
seraient libérés skali serait très bien
donc là haut niveau structure de pions
les noirs sont mieux puisqu'ils ont deux
blocs et les blancs en ont trois voire
appelé on va compter l'époque des blancs
les y en a un là irruption tout seul
tout compte donc comme un bloc et là il
ya un bloc de 2 donc 2 contre trop 3,3
pour les blancs deux contre deux pour
les noirs c'est mieux pour les noirs
ouais les pièces noires sont assez
bonnes assez efficace c'est assez bien
placé sur le cac les âges certains
peut-être un peu mais
une tape sur gsm quand même donc ici
probablement légère avantage maintenant
qu'avec 10 h 7 prévient g5 vladimir
kramnik jeu tour des f2 voilà ça c'est
le signe d'une attaque vers le bras
blancs vers le roi noir et la limite on
se dit qu'il a pas toi revenir parce que
il a quand même le foot des deux qui
peut se réveiller un qui peut attaquer
le roi les deux tours qui sont en
position
ici il va falloir qu'il joue la percée
f4 f5 la demi-heure pour essayer
d'attaquer le roi noir c'est chaud c'est
chaud parce que f4 f5 même une fois
qu'on l'a joué et bien ça ne menacent
toujours rien stefan sahm nasria
s'appelle d'ailleurs peter des gosses
jouent faux à 8 tranquille vas-y joue
n'y a pas peur ouais bah non et c'est
lui qui prépare pour l'instant mais il
peut pas condamner un problème pourquoi
pas si les deux carling protégés de
qu'elle prendrait le pian et après les
cavaliers prendrai mes des peu menacée
peut-être aux cinq bons salaires de 5
c'est délicat division vins d'exception
bouge mais qui a aidé 89,5 alors une
remarque sur cette variante 1 des clés
noires rouges les caraïbes l'on y entre
ouais indiqué de l'an bouge les pions
noirs avancent ouais c'est ça bref cet
équilibre de la terreur à bouger il faut
pas bouger une fois pas bougé d'alger 3
lames g3 intéressant la dame s'en va de
cette colonne mais et et ouais on voit
qu'elle soutient les pions à peut-être
les blancs vont jouer h 3 h 4 oui celui
de jésus cas de gestion tout à fait
quel revers de la médaille le cahier des
caps n'est plus protégé et peter les
coûts en profite tout de suite à avec le
coup j'essaie de g6 voilà idée le fou
vient angers cet attaquant le fodec de
camiers des cartes attaque le cahier des
4 et 6 qui va les bouches et b5 idée 5
yum
ça y est et là ça y est ils se libèrent
égaux et avec une pression et c'est
l'explosion c'est une explosion c'est
l'explosion m'a dit mercredi que joe
f500 tant que ça commence à tourner au
vinaigre le salaire bon quand même une
m5 parce que bon et bien on va quand
même que les tours vont s'ouvrir sur la
lépi que laurent noir et l'arrière donc
ça a l'air quand même dangereux la
menace positionnelle de skull 5 c'est
sans doute de jouer f6 stéphane boucher
les noirs c'est effectivement ça a l'air
curieux d'avoir mis les deux tours comme
ça
une fois qu'on a installé un pion f6 et
bien le
evans est très mal placé nous faut et
fuite très mal placée aussi bref ces
deux pièces noires soirée hors jeu ouais
le roi noir faible avis donc la menace
positionnelle ces deux journées festives
mais là juste à temps fou g7 bouger
cette voie là parce que juste avant on
faisait 6 si on prenait d'un cavalier
évidemment on sacrifie une tour pour 2k
mali oui c'est toujours bien oui là on
peut plus il ya quand même trois pièces
qui protège à 23 sièges des deux tours
contre lequel fondera des anecdotes en
fait tout ça mais ça fait beaucoup
ce qui est beaucoup moins bien alors là
ça y est c'est à partir de ce moment là
on peut dire que les noirs sont déjà
mieux
un tout petit peu mieux ailleurs à noter
que le sexe car il est des quatre
qu'attaquer et y'a pas moyen de le
défendre efficacement
non non pas moyen non il n'y a pas de ya
pas de solution parce que il ya un autre
problème aussi stéphane sait que lille a
le cou aux pros f5 régulièrement avec
l'option du cap qui va se retrouver
attaquer et parfois 8
ouais et par la tour e 8 ce cavalier h7
qui peut sauter sur la 4g 5 ce qui a
aidé cette qui pousse sauter sur la case
c5
ça fait beaucoup de flèches mais on sent
que la position noir peut se desserrer
comme un ressort à se déplier que se
déplier comme un ressort et exploser
donc à la gueule des plantes
wey kaw les ce2 qualifié d'homme la
bougie ce qu'a d'ailleurs plus bouger
lors qu'ils ne bougent et celui-là il
est là laisse le plus avancé est
finalement donc inconvénients stéphane
le cabinet privé c3 donc c'est tout de
suite on pense à deux choses première
chose le coupé cette dernière réussit
tout de suite deuxième chose ou sur
quatre est moins protégé les moins
protégés les bougies le cavalier ce
n'était pas tout à fait pareil c'était
pas tout à fait pareil sa protégée ou
quatre mais là c'est donc la lys et sa
guitare le conte profit de caryl ces
cinq mots très forts menacent le purin 4
mais simplement cavalli produit 1 4 avec
un gain technique un gain de rieux le
roi blanc faible par moments a eu le roi
blanc commence est faible ça obligerait
donné le fou en fait c'est horrible très
très délicat un report il faut pas s'il
ya un problème alors le coup qu'on a
envie de jouer c'est de défendre ses
pions oui enfin moi on peut contre
attaquer tout de suite déjà quand même
alors non mais dans un premier temps ou
envisager les défenses possible du pion
aux quatre oui alors quelles sont elles
madame ou trois par exemple des 1300 et
une dame le trois-mâts mentionné ce coup
protéger
trois possibilités pour deux formations
mais là il ya eu près f5 qu'est ce qui
se passe en moi la tour 8 qui se
réveille c'est horrible contre la dame
au 3 mai évidemment le qca très
attaquées il est perdu il est perdu est
perdu qu'il est perdu c'est terminé
c'est pas possible de me 3 c'est pas
possible ça marche pas donc après
qu'elle et ses sacs un autre coup
possible aux étés damev 4c sanction
terrible ça perd tout de suite il ya eu
500 fourchette fourchette dames et
cavaliers attaque et la dame et le
cavalier se gagne une pièce et en plus
le tour en sibérie un sac et une pièce
sais pas c'est donc pas viable non plus
on voit pas d'autres coins surtout avec
quatre nominations une approche est
franche et autres il ya d'autres
possibilités
on ne peut plus défendre le pion au gatt
à partir de cette position est vraiment
qu'ils essaient 3 c'est pas possible ou
plus étaient des quatre reprises oui
donc la trame n'est que juin coûts
intermédiaires tout le projet 6 voilà
donc ils cassent un peu
la structure durable en fortran puisque
sa menace puis on prend deux cavaliers
avec échec avec échec c'est important
qu'il faut reprendre est la même
maintenant il peut faire d'un autre rare
puisqu'il ya plus qu on prend avec cinq
exactement ce qu'on disait c'est ça la
pointe c'est que la tour vite ne peut
pas revenir en jeu puisqu'il dure
épreuve
voilà par contre là les noirs pourrait
jouer dès 5 où j'ai pas un non événement
une chose cette chose mais il pourrait
peut-être jouer des simples et noir à
leur dessein que d'abord c'est peut-être
ça sous des deux côtés ils peuvent le
faire mais c'est pas c'est pas clair
qu'on va voir alors qu'est-ce qui l'a
choisi il a choisi quelque chose de plus
percutant c'est solide plus percutant
voilà e 5 e 5 ceux qui avaient des
cartes étaient bien placés étaient
ennuyeux il n'a pas beaucoup d'occases
il en a qu'une voie là puisqu'on voit
que s'il vient à f3 ce qui n'a pas été
jouée au bénin il ya donc sa perdition
au caire sa pierre della valle pointures
en attaquant la tour en plus la tour qui
est enfermé ce n'est pas manchot
elle est enfermée pour autant faire
c'est joli c'est géométriques dont
presse à berne tour pourrait voir les
cavaliers américains piano purée suite
vous faites beaucoup lequel près de 5 la
seule case disponible encore c'est le
bouquet bis et de stephen donc c'est
pareil ça bien repoussé le cavalier mans
par contre ça crée un gros trou sur la
classe des 5 1 c'est à dire que si les
leblanc le temps de jouer car les c3 car
il décède c'est pas si mal
ben qui y seraient ils feraient même
légèrement mais c'est sûrement mieux
mais ils ont peut-être pas le temps et
non puisque picard l'écho et là ils
jouent b5 olympico et la [ __ ] haricots
jouber 5 donc trouve son contre jeu très
vite la menace puis on prend ces quatre
comme prince ekale descente peut pas
reprendre avant la pause du four b2 qui
seront prises par la dame a voilà voilà
voilà
il faut toujours voir ça et là c'est
dans cette position très délicate
chronique gaff gaff gaff qui fait la
faute
il traque il a joué tu en prends pions
il a pris un des cinq coups qui perd
tout simplement
il fallait jouer là-bas les c3
probablement fait les défendre ce qu'il
fallait jouer calais c3 et c3 avec une
pointe avec une pointe qu'on va vous
montrer voilà sur puis on prend ces
quatre cantons c4 on joue sur français
cap quand même et sur dame proche d'eux
voilà là il ya tout rhdp un enfermement
voilà et la dame est ce assez jolie
hilary perdu la dame est perdus c'est
joli il attaque et alors on voit qu'elle
a plus de gaz à voir quels sont les
caisses de la dame il y en a dans cette
position
une autre 4 5 6 elle a passé ses six 12
mai royal tout tout sans prise ces trois
là sont prises soit par le cavalier par
l'autre ouais ces trois là sont
contrôlés également alors paladares la
deuxième est évidemment tout le reste
qui est sur la colonne est contrôlé par
la tour b 1 ouais la dame éprise salle
bauquier oui ça s'appelle un fou
empoisonné un foisonnement général en
b2c le pion aux poses on revoit l'image
7 c'est un faux empoisonnée c'est
vraiment c'est un pion c'est un choix
personnel c'est dire que si la dame bien
le prendrai bien moins fermement
donc ça c'était possible pour trafic et
surtout il gardait le contrôle la casse
des 5 pourquoi il n'a pas joué simple à
dire chronique
alors pour première hypothèse évidemment
la plus plausible c'est qu'il est
envahie note
il n'a pas beaucoup de temps oui parce
que sa vie partisane et sert minutes un
temps sûrement évidemment et deuxième
chose ça lui plaisait pas dans la mesure
où après pions prend ses quatre pions
français 4 la structure des blancs
étaient affaiblies ouais donc si on se
base sur des facteurs positionnelle
soyez place régulièrement ces cas
reviennent faible puis en plus bon là
quand même la prise en b2 reste en l'air
si vous bougez aucune des pièces parce
que des combos jeunes cavaliers la dame
peut prendre
oui après le séchage oui mais tout à
fait non mais il va falloir d'abord père
peintre en jouant fou hein ouais ou faux
à 3 et après cavaler seynois flamand
c'est l'ombre mais tout à fait mais ici
c'est est encore tenable c'était encore
jouable
c'est ça qu'il fallait faire après b5
rami qui a joué pions prend b5 et là ça
va aller très très vite à l'hôpital co a
vu la pointe sur les coûts a vu la
combine est la combine est alors ce
qu'il faut noter c'est que le cac a
laissé deux ici oui ce cas rien ces deux
il est sous la menace de la tour s'est
vite donc la leko trouve l'idée il faut
éliminer le pion central fort des blancs
pv y trouve la solution cavalli prend
voilà cavalli prendre puisque avec une
pointe stéphane c'est que sur fou prend
cavaliers qui a été joué et on a
l'impression que ça défend le cavalier
ouais mais en fait non non pas du tout
ce que le x 8 clou le fou aucun voilà
c'est là qu'on peut prendre le cavalier
et c'est la partie si la partie tour
conseil doit être libre à la partie
alors voilà il y aura échec coran on n'a
pas le droit de prendre la tour oui et
donc il ya échange de pièces mais des
noirs ont récupéré le pion aux quatre
centrales très exactement c'est
important en plus dans une tour en c2
qui est très active mais on va revoir ce
qui vient de se passer est ce que cette
tour attaque le four b2 et les noms on
va récupérer pour biesheim fait autant
revenons à stéphane à cette version là
après qu'elle ait procuré aux 4
tout de suite à des menaces on attaque
la tour f 2 ah oui on attaque le cavaly
ces deux safebook a donc tout simplement
pas le choix non pas le choix on est au
dessus de tout ce qu'il a dit maintenant
je tort quand ces deux il ya ce fameux
cloud h mais il ya la tour qui attaquent
le four b2 et l'option de 5 qui va être
récupérée ou alors par l'option soi même
ce cas là il faut d'abord protéger le
fou donc les noirs on récupère le clan
donc ils vont gagner un peu en finale
et en plus le roi blanc est faible 8 le
rôle dans les faibles et en blanc la
majorité centrale deux pions noirs aux
cent contre 0 mazagan qui avantage
allait bien passé et là ça devient très
chaud donc ici un crâne nick a une
position extrêmement délicate
probablement perdante il ajouté les c3
on est beaucoup
alors ça défend le fou d2 par la tour
par eto'o et en plus ce qu'est lancé
trois ans le voit et c'est d'installer
ce qu'on appelle une blocage
voilà il faut bloquer sur cases blanches
empêcher les pieds-noirs l'avancé si on
peut laisser bloquer cette option sur
les cases des 6 7 5
on a des chances de tenir même si on
absolument en revanche des questions
commencent à avancer ça devient très
très difficile
pour pro tour pour prendre tôt pour
prendre pour prendre il a bien joué
hôpital etc on ne se presse pas d'aller
récupérer le pion b5 subtil il ajoute
qu'à les g5 d'abord périgée 5 voilà
alors quel gsm que ça met la pression
sur e4 sa besace de guînes directement
stéphane on peut montrer un par exemple
sur une faute si on prend 1,6 va
sûrement prendre à un cadre suivi deux
des cinq ans et ce serait terrible
cavalli provoqué ce viennent tout de
suite qu'ils avaient des enfants elle a
des scènes sagan tout de suite puisque
si le cavaly bouge et bien aujourd hui
des quatre avec échec puisque le fou à 8
ferait chèque au roi qui est en h1 et la
dame serait perdu quand il peut il donc
ici supposons par exemple qui essaient 5
voilà des quatre échecs au roi un échec
au roi et la gamme au compteur morizet
prend la dame à la terrible donc ici
c'est la menace dans cette position ont
masqué prend 4 celui de d5 problème donc
c'est pour femmes rapatrie s'en fout
voilà il se rapproche du roi fou prend
fou on va voir prend hélas hélas l'échec
en baisse est très fort cet échec petit
échec
pourquoi bien parce que ça amène la dame
sur une case où elle contrôle très bien
mais kas blanche comme l'était rallonge
important si on veut pousser c'est une
opération sur les cases noires sont
savent assez tranquille il ya le fou
il ya la tour en plus derrière ça va
encore orange est un il faut bien mettre
le roi quelque part et maintenant on
reprend tranquillement en v5
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est un pion de
plus pour les noirs et on ne voit pas de
solution pour éviter l' avance de
section dédiée ici ses positionnements
perdu mes plates bien évidemment on ne
sait pas si c'est un statut puisque
c'est du semi rapides [ __ ] mais qu'on
peut faire des gaffes h4 un tacle
cavaliers chasse pas quel est le
problème si ça fait bien encore plus
laurent blanc déjà lancé les dernières
voilà il est il est plus à ça près
comment les classes après avoir
quadrillé aussi ça c'est pas mal ça
c'est ça c'est toujours ça c'est super
parce que lecavalier voit la menace de
revenir sur casey 4 où il est superbe
parce qu'il est contrôlé par an qui ont
donc très forts ils étaient des fenêtres
c'est celle là et il attaque les cases
pré durable du prêt de rois de kramnik
donc il serait très très fort ce qu'elle
m'a dit c'est sur saône cavaliers à la
casse par offrant machiavélique
l'espérance qu'avait lieu 4 ça c'est la
ressource de karmic attaque l'option des
six way et menaces fourchette surtout
serre si les noir jaune des cinq il ya
cavaliers des six attaques d'armé tour
tout à fait il faut donc trouver des
recettes défend l'option des six et en
même temps attaques qui ont acheté à
tempérer donc ça c'est sûr
la difficile pour la dîmière un
traitement qui trouve un coup ils jouent
g5
ouais pas mal mal il faut venir sur
l'exercice voilà et puis bon là comme ça
les plans sont protégés et puis ils
menacent aussi pu en prendre ombrage
61.4 cavalière 4 ça c'est bien joué
voilà le calice viennent s'installer sur
la case maintenant le pion g5 est
attaqué il y en a ce nom le plonger
sainte n'est pas attaqué puisqu'il est
défendu encore peintre qui vit au 4
avril et encore des médecins est menacée
voilà la menace est bien sûr des cinq
ici peut-être que
venir à rater une petite tente qui
aurait pu lui permettre d'obtenir
quelque chose
ouais il n'a pas vu je pense qu'il n'a
pas vu le coup cavaliers fonction des
six car les promotions des silhouettes
pas mal parce que leurs ouailles voilà
l'idée c'est que si on prend le cas mali
avec la dame dont on est obligé devant
lequel quasiment obligée puisqu'il ya ça
tape la tour donc voilà dan franck et
audi et voilà et là on voit que la dame
blanche en trois on montre tout de suite
le coup
ouais tout retour en arrière est ce que
si le client vient reprendre la dame
blanche viendra prendre la twa 8 qui
n'est pas dire avec échec donc c'est
donc un clouage aux comores et ses
emplois et après tourcoing f cabourg est
bien ici qu'est ce qu'on voit est bien
c'est qu'on va bloquer ce pion un pion
aux cinq sur la case aux quatre attendez
je vais enlever ces quelques flèches
on va bloquer ce pion éventuellement sur
une case blanche en 4 et ensuite on peut
essayer de tenir avec un roi faible
comme ça ouais on mais c'est très très
dur
les noirs sont mieux c'est évident des
très bonnes chances de gain pour les
noirs probablement gagnant mais ici on
peut encore espérer s'en sortir donc
dans cette position vladimir kramnik a
vraisemblablement raté ce qui prouve
qu'il ya toujours des chances il ya
toujours des chances en saura sûrement
semi rapides à 9,60 rien il ya les
oublis sont extrêmement fréquents la
preuve ses chroniques par exemple ici ne
vois pas quel écran 10 mai donc là il a
jugé prend 1,6 oui mais le problème
c'est que voilà après fou prend voilà
faut prendre
et là on me met en pétard s'attaquer la
dame par un dérèglement savez tout à
fait d'alger 3 l'api terre les coujoux
bien très bien même si ce donc
ils surent protège son pion g6 protège
ses six ils commencent à rentrer s'y
recueillir des idées bonnes à saisir le
tout contrôlé quasiment il y avait la
dame contrôler quasi blanche oui et puis
quand il veut il joue décidé l'intérieur
ils menacent des singles donc là c'est
tout simplement terminer rouages de a
été jouée dessin à ça y est enfin et là
on voit que cette majorité de cuivres la
faune saddam et on voit pas comment les
blancs maintenant de popularité il a
pris le temps avant les poussées que oui
oui mais en général c'est ce qu'on dit
c'est les pions canton les avances ça
gagne calé j'ai 5 fu pranger 5
évidemment si on prend hélas il ne faut
pas rater le dernier geste technique de
cette partie oui on a envie d'amener la
tour sur la colonne h c'est à dire sur
pour faire un échec mais pour faire des
chèques dévastateur qui
conjugué avec le cavalier isle adam vont
faire un math rapide pour ça on ne joue
pas à manger cette sas qui serait la
gaffe ça serait bien grave puisque là on
se met dans le clouage du fou du fou à
quel point tu peux plus bouger une
plante au rayon car il prend tout
simplement le cas on peut pas reprendre
ce que le roi en échec comme ça ce
serait une erreur donc ils trouvent le
bon coup l'auteur ou toujours c'est la
tour qui vient en cet or cette voie là
c'est donc pas le roi qui d'espacé la
tour mais la tour qui contourne le roi
donc c'était un bon moyen ici menace de
venir en rage cette voie la tour sete
qui fera échec celui de cavaliers h3 qui
fera fourchette qui ramassera le tour et
ce sera terminé ce sera terminé pour ces
deux derniers essais de pratique hélas
hélas coûte rankin des médecins qu
facile alors d'un 9,5 ça attaque la tour
ces deux ça contrôler la casse et 8 qui
empêche un échec
oui et en plus cette dame est super
mieux il avoir les mieux classés caen le
6 et le contrôle à la callas tnf
on est en train de faire une cage pour
le roi voilà et la tourache 7 va gagner
la partie
oui en plus la dame peut augmenter en
bénin en général c'est matt à peu près
dans l'est dans les dix prochains coups
sur la meilleure défense des blancs bon
c'est un peu une évaluation
d'ordinateurs mais là il n'y a plus
aucune solution pour tenir voilà ces
deux là c'est vraiment être à la
tourache 7 suivi de gains matériels très
très élevé faut donner la dame et on est
mal très vite oui hein sinon les maths
donc surprenant très deux parties
surprenant pourquoi parce que dès
l'ouverture on ne comprend pas ce que
font les blancs et on ne comprend pas ce
que font les noirs c'est à dire que
chacun des 2 sort ses pièces d'une
certaine façon qui est un peu
surprenante
d'ailleurs la distance quoi les blancs
prennent d'eux
pas de beaucoup d espace avec cette
fameuse et audomarois si oui et puis
cette formation-là hérisson avec les
pions qui sont en attente tranquille qui
empêche les blancs d'avancé et en fait
finalement les bleus perdent pas ce
qu'ils avancent leurs pions peut-être
aussi bien oui mais lorsque ça je me
rappelle une phrase de yossi dorfman qui
me qui disait quand les noirs votre
chemin et hérissons si vous n'arrivez
pas à gagner en moins de vingt coups
vous allez perdre 1 me ce qui veut dire
qu'en fait les noirs qui ont l'air de
faire une formation qui va être mauvaise
sur le long terme puisque donne très peu
d'espacé pour manoeuvrer l amf est bonne
selon en fait elle est bonne sur le long
terme il faut tout de suite les
pulvériser avant qu'ils aient réussi à
mettre leurs pièces et leurs pions il
sans aucun frais des pics sont bien
informés ouais tout à fait donc ici même
l'a dit mercredi que quand il allait
blanc quelqu'un d'un spécialiste
un spécialiste du jeu du jeu d'échecs
puisqu'il est champion du monde n'a pas
trouvé de solution contre le hérisson et
donc c'est s'est fait tout simplement
démontré qu' il n'est pas imbattable
alors on va peut-être devoir une des
victoires de l'adie mir 1 2 alors
stéphanoise dix minutes ouais mais dix
minutes et non mais la position
intéressante décor à la partie mais on
va peut-être monter la pression
puisqu'il aurait justement de dix
minutes très bien que c'est intéressant
donc je sais pas laquelle
parce qu'il y en a deux il y en a deux
je pense qu'il vaudrait mieux montrer
c'est louis lahaye les blancs oui c'est
louis là les blancs puisque il a gagné
donc on va le rappeler une berlinoise
mais c'était plutôt suite à des fautes
de peter les coûts alors que de la
première partie du match était très bien
c'est la fameuse grünfeld alors je ne
sais pas si c'est celle là a lancé pas
celle là
stéphane g 10 clicquot ça doit être
c'est bon c'est ça c'est celle là donc
on va on va y revenir très vite
voilà donc réalisation difficile
aujourd'hui pour notre avis thater non
ce que nous tweetons rapidement quels
passages allons nous montrer on va
remontrer vite fait les premiers coups
non là c'est une bonne felde on a déjà
présenté sa sé kasparov entre dakar ni
contrôle kasparov
ouais ouais voilà et kramnik rejoue la
même que contre kasparov
après ces cinq qui joue ce fait vous aux
trois dames à cinq dames d2 avec échange
de dames rapide way qui ont caillassé
six tours c'est un déplacement pièce et
là évidemment pendant le direct de ce
fameux championnat du monde mémorable eh
bien nous avions proposé puis on prend
des 4 comprend des cartes et les changes
les dames ouais
suivant une indication de brumath qui
dit dans la zone fait quand j'ai demandé
à changer d'âme ils s'en sortent
toujours
eh bien on va voir que c'est pas si
simple ajout de tourbe et avait tourné
un tournant c'est par sa non touché 4
dont c'était pas ça je crois pas si les
tous premiers sets dans un habitant de
crac ici c'est sûr c'est pas tout à fait
la même en fait c'était pas te croire
plan des dom voilà donc ici on est en
finale et la toux des blancs on sait ce
pion pas céder le problème des blancs
c'est que le roi pour l'instant et au
centre ouais petit rock dessins qu'il
faut il avancer très vite autour des 8
est maintenant 3e 1 jouée par kasparov
avec les blancs quand il avait les
blancs il ya une dizaine ou une
quinzaine d'années je me rappelle c'est
dans son livre bizarre ce court livre
qu'on conseille à tout le monde
l'épreuve du temps de guerre les
questions s'agisse à lévis et à 8,6 pour
les noirs ne s'y risquerait de casser le
centre blanche en plus stéphane
s'attaque lui qu'avec ça attaque le
cavalier pose la question est l'objet de
bouchers tout de suite ça bouge pas le
fouet fin il va en cinq cavaliers prend
cavaliers fou prend les chroniques
spéciaux
liste de ces finales à terre de fou
qu'il joue extrêmement bien il avait
déjà battu joël lautier dans quelque
chose de similaire f4 cédé 6 - f2 ça y
est l'arbre est à l'abri sa voix est
donc ici on se dit que les blancs sont
très bien pourquoi si des noirs joué 6
et bien non je vois fou c4 mais dont la
valve anti son jour même des 4 5 et 6
oui oui exactement ça a l'air plus fort
on va montrer aussi ce sas et après 2,6
a pas l'air bon il y a eu 5 nous font
mouche ou nouveau tout en bas 3 rebonds
la craie attaqueront bord on attaque
pour ces trois fous des quatre en
attaque ont la taille jusqu'à ce qu'ils
s'en aillent en 9 8 mois là et là on les
plante des six blum et c'est net
avantage donc ici il ya un problème
c'est que et bien les blancs vont
développer leur pièce et non c'est pas
trop ce qu'ils font donc peter les
coujoux le coût de 5
bien vu pas mal et maintenant kramnik
combine fous ces cinq bien jouer il faut
débloquer il faut laisser passer ce
option même ici c'est un sacrifice de
pions ceux des femmes c'est un sacrifice
de plus en plus il est le pion à 4 oui
ça mousse autour sacrifice je prends
tout reprend son prolifique et autres
parce que la voilà il joue au golf trois
attaquants le pion et les noirs peuvent
pas trop le protéger parce que s'il joue
g5
c'est un sacrifice de plus moi même
s'ils jouent gsm que c'est pas bon elles
peuvent juger 5 et noir n'ont ils
peuvent pas ignorer pour ses sets mais
s'est passé c'est très compliqué fou 17
d'ailleurs ça va on va s'y retrouver un
peu puisque là les noirs votre tour
s'est vite surtout à vladimir kramnik
récupère pas le pion puisque elle va
passer c'est pas le but je vous fous des
trois tours s'est vite torcéen voilà il
faut pas 300 ils étaient obligés et
maintenant j'ai 5 c'était donc un vrai
cette fille de pions voilà maintenant
maintenant il peut jouer juste un
missile avait joué avant et rue h
théâtre s'était pas c'était pas clair
c'est pas clair tour c'est cette voie la
tour prends tout reprendre les noirs ont
toujours en plus mais là on s'aperçoit
que leur position mais pas et pas bon
bah oui de tomber cette attaque et on
voit pas comme la menace et aux cinq
suites des systèmes des femmes
avec un pion qui passe en x 4 rangées 4
mais voilà ces droits - oui oui c'est
fort ça non mais c'est très beau c'est
une très belle finale très très bien
joué par l'univers krasniqi voilà on va
passer quelques courageux 10 et là
maintenant il récupère un pion miramas
transcender cette voie là tour 17
net avantage pour vladimir kramnik à
noter que ces échanges les tours ici ne
gagnera pas il faut pas changer les
tours il faut échanger tout retour des
quatre le fou de peter l'écho est mal
placé food est un échec
on monte en rêve c'est qu'on n'a pas
peur ouais il faut pas avoir pas mal
parce que c'est chaud là on remarque ici
que le roi blanc a plus qu'une seule
case la case au 5 et qui pourrait
bientôt ne plus la voir
d'ailleurs après h 4 et 6 ça y est si il
est en échec il est mat quand même est
bon mais bon mais on ne voit pas trop
comment il pourrait être en échec
kramnik a vu plus loin évidemment h 30
et 5 h pranger 5
et là c'est le coup ici qui fait gagner
la partie il est extrêmement compliqué
on a très peu de temps pour le commenter
c'est l'essai si le grand coup de cette
partie moi c'est le coût de la partie à
noter qu'il faut pas tomber dans le
piège des femmes le mauvais coup serait
d'en prendre six cas là rebond qui a
l'air avec a l'air très bon
malheureusement il se heurte à tous les
quatre matins ouais ski ski tout de
suite demande qu'il est papa ce qui
démontre que le coup n'était en réalité
est pas le meilleur est clair il faut
bien le dire donc ici il ya déjà on se
rappelle évidemment de shorts qu'entre
beddiaf ski qui s'était fait planter un
battant un coup dans une finale qu'il
allait gagner à rennes c'était
incroyable et c'était du même style e5
alors ça c'est curieux parce qu'alors
salah soutien aux quatre faire le plein
en scène qui est bon évidemment le prix
le pjd est celle qui était blanc est en
prise on va démontrer les options sont
encore voilà bon à l'intéressé
évidemment c'est évidemment que
ça va casser la structure des pions
noirs alors on va montrer qu'un tour
prend des cinq sapeurs en ligne
s'appellera après tout en dix-sept échec
échec alors là plusieurs possibilités
roi j'évite qui perd tout de suite à
cause de fou c4 qui trouve la tour qui
trouve la tour royale suite qui alertent
nabeul roi et fuite par exemple ça perd
très vite après roy prend et fils mais
la smat l'onas mater c'est très dur à
parer le pion à vence ouais c'est
terminé donc ici après tomber cet échec
furuhashi courage 6 forcée voilà
mais la belle a tout simplement c'était
femme incroyable le groupe foulée
tranquille menace roi prend pions m6
avec le mat en fils à durable alors et
exemple si les noirs faisait par exemple
j'en prends par exemple de cherouine
exemple reprend 2,5
ouais ici il ya le courant a aussi sa
tête la tour à tapis à tour et menacent
tous rage sept matchs avec le roi c'est
fou ce matin avec et le fou contre le
geste est droitier menaces et se termine
ouais donc ici bon c'est très compliqué
locaux et 5
mais ces efforts nous en a dit le plus
possible tout reprend des cinq paires de
manière forcée donc il faut prendre avec
le volant relève forcément là et la
chronique conclu pourquoi prendre 5 avec
un pion passé au centre on va on va
regarder là c'est ça l'idée en fait tout
simplement ces [ __ ] de fabrication d
donc là j'apprends avec mon enfant vous
désirez noir essayer de créer au moins
aussi un pion passé ils sont bien le
retard des six parce que plus on va vite
tour des huit on passe le fou pour
empêcher les échecs four f5 en plus
empêche g4 oui donc ça contrôle tout
faussé 6,8 à l'éco abandonne ses projets
de pousser sont plongés et la d7 le coup
de massue
la menace c'est de le roi des six ouais
surtout prend 17 on perd tout de suite
suite à ce clouage tour b737 kilt ou
moins facile pour moi là je trouve leur
peut pas bouger tout simplement viré le
roi des risques après dix-sept plus tard
et kolo touré fuite et la chronique le
termine avec tour des quatre menaces
dame
ouais et si la tour viande ebit est bien
mal simplement des six on voit aussi ses
poteaux
oui on voit aux 6 3 2 6 et les drames et
les deux gagnent et on gagne facilement
donc voilà une belle victoire de kramnik
bien dans son style très positionnait
les militaires l'écho n'a plus rejoué
l'anophèle quand je vous invite à voir
comment on gagne ces genres de finale
parce que ça là on dit
mme hivon même en gagnant avec ce que
l'on gagne le fou finalement oui
maintenant la dame souffre au camp mais
la gagner c'est quand même la gagner
mais ça mais bon à ce niveau-là conseil
diagonale le sauna aux actionnaires ont
heureusement qu'il reste confiant à 2,1
sinon ça serait nul sinon ce serait nous
le tueur fou contre tours et voilà il
faut garder le but 1 2 c'est ce pion qui
fera la différence
oui alors très vite stéphane quelques
nouvelles en bref wait du monde dont
l'inde à sting qui vient de se terminer
le traditionnel tournoi de noël web
donne tu avais terminé second je crois
une année second en 97 90 en train de
jouer bien il ya très longtemps
effectivement première manche j'avais
perdu contre sa de l'air qui a gagné le
tournoi après avec cet ennemi sur une
offre un score impressionnant
et là c'est l'indien sachets kieran
krishnan ingall moi c'est un espoir
abbas est un espoir indien oui oui tout
à fait il a je crois qu'il a 17 ans
extrêmement fort 2600 bientôt donc à la
suite d'un homme quoi il gagne avec 6
sur 9
bosco en premier tout seul de ce tournoi
sur un service vers l'asie un toutou les
futurs champions seront sûrement
asiatiques les futurs champions seront
sans doute asiatiques déjà un évidement
mais y est c'est le seul pour l'instant
dans les vingt premiers mondiaux mais je
pense que d'ici on a surtout très peur
des chinois huawei les chinois je les
aime bien je crois que les miens
les indiens ça bouge déjà au niveau
féminin c'est à peu près bouclé si on
allonge et dit polgar sillonnait la
meilleure joueuse du monde
donc voila sinon il ya un match donc un
ordinateur
john van der wiel est en train de battre
rebelles le fameux programme rebelles le
forum mondial va bien il le bat bien de
1 pour l'instant c'est pas mal
à noter qu'il n'a jamais perdu deux
parties contre les ordinateurs jeune
femme d'erbil c'est un des rares humains
qui fait de la résistance avec rami
consignes qui font un travail qui est
très fort également match l'écho kramnik
évidemment
sinon à part ça il y en aurait beaucoup
de tournois mais qu'en dise ici avec
andy qui arrivent alors oui ça démarre
quand ça démarre jeudi le 12 le 12 donc
la semaine prochaine et donc je pense
qu'on va fermer spéciale des coms et
pendant trois semaines on va être obligé
et non il ya également stéphane le match
ponomariov kornoi ouais il va également
être comme très intéressante parce sympa
mais je veux dire que ça vous pas vu
comme c'est comme ça vous avez laissé
derrière fois donc on se donne rendez
vous très beau programme du mois de
janvier à la semaine prochaine pour
mécaniser début de ce tournoi
et puis après mais des spéciales avec
des images puisqu'on va aller en
hollande film et tout ça
oui